[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بكم في نقاش يمكن لكم كالعاده
ان تتفاعل مع ما يقول الوضوء في البرنامج
على صفحتنا على فيسبوك وعلى صفحه البرنامج
على تويتر نقاشنا عن القضيه الفلسطينيه
الاحداث التاريخيه الاخيره بدا بالربيع
العربي مرورا بالحزمه الصحيه وصولا الى
الحرب في اوكرانيا
كثيرين بان العالم قلص من اهتمامه بالقضيه
الفلسطينيه مع ان العنف تفاقما في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه و داخل اسرائيل وخلف العديد من
القتل في صفوف الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
صحيح انا الاداره الامريكيه انتقلت من
الجمهور ترامب الى الديمقراطي ولكن
نتنياهو هو الذي عاد الى رئاسه حكومه على
يمين اليمين هل خرجنا كليا عن منطقه
السلام والعوده الى طويله المفاوضات ما هي
الافاق المفتوحه حتى تتجدد الاداره
الفلسطينيه سعيد بان يناقش الموضوع وما
معي من القاهره حسين هريدي وهو مساعد وزير
الخارجيه المصري الاسبق سعيد بان يكون
معنا من رام الله نبيل عمرو وزير صيني
سابق عاني عن التعريف سعيد بان يكون معنا
من تلابيب ايال زيسر وهو بروفيسور في قصه
دراسات الشرق الاوسط في جامعه تل ابيب
اهلا وسهلا بكم ابدى مع ضيفه من رام الله
هل تشاطر هذه الفكره وهذه المقالات التي
نقراها والتي تقول وهو طبعا منذ اكثر من
10 سنوات
الاهتمام بالقضيه الفلسطينيه
تراجع لاسباب عددتها ولكن هناك اسباب اخرى
انا وافقك على ذلك بكل اسف طبعا
وهنالك عوامل ذاتيه وموضوعيه ادت الى ما
نحن فيه الان من تهميش لموضوع حل القضيه
الفلسطينيه القضيه الفلسطينيه قائمه ما
دام هنالك شعب فلسطيني وحقوق فلسطينيه
واحتلال في القضيه ضد القائمه انما هنالك
تهميش الاهتمام بها العوامل المتعدده
العامل الاساسي العامل الاساسي هو
الانقلاب الذي حصل على اوسلو لانه بنيت
السياسه الفلسطينيه لفتره طويله على اساس
اتفاقات اوسلوه وعوده بانها هنالك امكانيه
لايجاد حلول وعندما حصل الانقلاب على
اوسلو تراجع الوضع الفلسطيني على الصعيد
التفاوض اضافه الى ذلك
الدخول العالم العربي الذي هو الحاضر
الرئيسي للفلسطينيين فيما سمي بالربيع
العربي خلق لكل دوله عربيه قضيه اكثر
سخونه ومباشره من القضيه الفلسطينيه
تشتت لاهتمام العربي نتيجه لذلك واذا ما
مضينا الى الامام قليلا نجد ان اسرائيل
حصل فيها ايضا انقلاب على العمليه
السياسيه واصبحت تفضل الحل الاقتصادي او
حل التسهيلات على الحل السياسي وبكل اسف
ان الادارتين
الديمقراطيه والجمهوريه ساروا في هذا
الاتجاه وبالتالي الوضع الطبيعي ضد الان
ضيف الان موضوع اوكرانيا هنالك حرب كونيه
تجري راس حربتها اوكرانيا روسيا ولكن يصل
الى العام كله وبالتالي نعم القضيه
الفلسطينيه تراجعت بسبب وجود قضايا منافسه
هي اكثر سخونه منها ولكن في نهايه المطاف
تظل القضيه الفلسطينيه اذا ضلت بلا حل هي
محرك اساسي في الشرق الاوسط ودائن ومن هنا
يجب ان ينظر الامر على ان الاهتمام تراجع
ولك القضيه طيب هي زي السر من تل ابيب
اريد رايك هل اسرائيل استغلت كل هذه
الظروف حتى تساهم في تهميش ايجاد حل
القضيه الفلسطينيه اكثر في اكثر
اسرائيل
في الامم المتحده لانه كان بي بيخلي ال
همم
دولهتين اسرائيليه
ولكن الغامقه العام في اسرائيل
لا يوجد
سياسيه كثيره
ليس هناك اي افق اتاكد بان العالم العربي
كمان والعلم باجمعه وصل الى هذه النتيجه
والسؤال المدبوق ماذا علينا ان نسال اذا
ليس هناك اي فرصه للقدوم الى الامام كما
العين بعد من الدول العربيه وصلت الى
النتيجه
لم يكن مهتم بخل القبيعه كانوا بالقضيه
الانسانيه العامه ولكن الدول العربيه ابدا
لن تكون مهتما بخالد القضيه لا لا ما كانت
همم الوضوء مثلا
ولكن دائما كانت لاعلى كرتون عربي
[موسيقى]
الفلسطيني
قبل ان اجيب على سؤال حضرتك احبه واكد ان
الشعب الفلسطيني موجود الشعب الفلسطيني اا
لن يستطيع احد انه يلغي من المعادله الشرق
اوسطيه ولن تستطيع اي حكومه اسرائيليه ان
تحول دون ان يمارس حقوقه الوطنيه المشهوره
كما اقرها المجتمع الدولي والامم المتحده
ما العمل ما العمل ده بيتوقف من يتحدث عن
منه
بنتحدث هل بنتحدث حضرتك عن الاخوه في
فلسطين هل بنتحدث عن واشنطن هل بنتحدث عن
اسرائيل هل بنتحدث عن العالم العربي اذا
جمعنا كل هذه الاطراف في سله واحده هنجد
انه اذا بدانا بالعلم العربي العلم العربي
همم ملتزم حتى هذه الساعه بمبادره السلام
التي سبق وانت رحها في عام 2002 ثم جدد
الالتزام بها في عام 2007
الحل الدوليتين ولا اقامه علاقات مع
اسرائيل من قبل الدول العربيه الا ب همم
قيام دوله فلسطين دوله فلسطين وعاصمتها
القدس الشرقيه بالنسبه للجانب الامريكي
الجانب الامريكي كما راينا خلال يعني اذا
اخذنا حضرتك الادارات الثلاثه همم اداره
الرئيس اوباما ثم اداره الرئيس ترامب ثم
الاداره اللي هي هنجد انه انه ال- ال- ال-
القسيس الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه في التعامل
مع القضيه الفلسطينيه استراتيجيه بتتذبذب
همم في اداره اوباما حاولت في ولايتها
الاولى في 2009 و2010 حاولت ان هي حضرتك
همم ترعى المفاوضات الفلسطينيه ال- ال-
الاسرائيليه ونتذكر انه في سبتمبر 2010
استضاف البيت الابيض قمه رباعيه همم شاركت
فيها مصر وهمم والسلطه الفلسطينيه والاردن
واسرائيل مثلها همم بنيامين ثانيه اهو
رئيس الحكومه في ذلك الوقت ثم همم
توقفت المفاوضات في
2014 لماذا توقفت المفاوضات في 2014 لانه
همم نتنياه وهمم المؤسسات الحاكمه ال- ال-
المؤسسات التنفيذيه في اسرائيل همم بدات
تو الورقه الايرانيه والبرنامج النووي
الايراني للحديث دوما على انه الامن
الاسرائيلي امن اسرائيل ده هو حضرتك
الاولويه الاولى الاسرائيلي لاسرائيل ثم
راينا كيف انه
الكونجرس الامريكي في عام 2015 مارس 2015
اما كان الاغلبيه في مجلس النواب
للجمهوريين كيف وجهه دعوه لمن مين نتنياهو
للتحدث في الجلسه مشتركه امام الكالس
الامريكي بدون بدون
التنسيق او اخدم موافقه او الضوء الاخضر
من البيت الابيض جاءت بعد اداره اوبا
توقفت المباحثات من ابريل 2014 حتى هذه
اللحظه جاءت اداره الرئيس ترامب التي تبنت
الخط الاسرائيلي بصوره تامه
وتمثل ذلك في امرين الامر الاول
الانحياز للطرح الاسرائيلي ان ايران بتمثل
تهديد وجوده لاسرائيل وخروج اداره ترامب
من الاتفاقيه النوويه في مايو 2018 ثم طرح
ما سمته ما سمته طبعا ده همم
خطا كبيرا انه صفقه القرن الا وهو مبادره
السلام التي طرحتها قبل اشهر من مغادرتها
البيت الابيض وهي كانت عباره عن ما يسمونه
في اسرائيل وفي همم اداره ترامب كانت
السلام الاقتصادي وانه عن طريق السلام
الاقتصادي بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
يمكن يمكن ان ان ان ان تتطور الامور
نصل الى مرحله جاء اداره الرئيس جو بايدن
طبعا
الخطاب الامريكي بالنسبه للقضيه
الفلسطينيه في ظل اداره همم الاداره
الحاليه خطاب ايجابي للغايه يعني حضرتك
لما استعرض سواء تصريحات الرئيس بايدن
تصرح تصريحات همم توني بلينكن همم
وزير الخارجيه او حضرتك في الاتصالات بين
الرئيس
والرؤساء والملوك العرب على سبيل المثال
وليس حاصل مع الرئيس السيسي دائما اداره
الرئيس بتؤكد على حق الفلسطينيين وحق
الاسرائيليين في الديمقراطيه وفي الامن
وفي الرخاء الاقتصاد لكن اداره الرئيس
باندا ترى وما نحن لا نتفق معها في هذا
ترى ان ظروف غير مواتيه حاليا لبن
لاستئناف المفاوضات الفلسطيني الاسرائيليه
فحضرتك الاطراف كلها الاطراف كلها المعنيه
غير انا اه قبل ما هختم بقى راضيه سؤال حق
الطرف الفلسطيني اا اا الطرف الفلسطيني
انا لن استطرد كثيرا في المشاكل اللي
بتعوق العمل الوطني الفلسطيني فهي معروفه
للجميع لكن انا يعني اا نتمنى همم اتمنى
على الاشقاء الفلسطينيين اجراء الانتخابات
العامه في عموم فلسطين حتى يختار الشعب
الفلسطيني قياده فلسطينيه جديده همم تعبر
عن تطلعاته الوطنيه المشروع قبل نصل الى
الجانب الفلسطيني نبيل عمرو
التطبيع مع عدد بناء الدول العربيه من
خلال اتفاقيه ابراهام هل هذا التطبيع ساهم
هو الاخر ايضا في ترك
هذا الحل حل القضيه الفلسطينيه جانبا
لفتره لان اسرائيل اصبحت تعول على المزيد
من الدول العربيه التي تطبع معها
بالتاكيد واذا كنا تحدثنا عن انقلاب داخل
اسرائيل على عمليه السلام
فنتحدث الان على شيء يشبه ذلك على الصعيد
العربي لان السياسه الفلسطينيه بنيت على
اساس المبادره العربيه للسلام التي اشترطت
العلاقات مع اسرائيل بقيام الدوله
الفلسطينيه او على الاقل باعتراف اسرائيل
بان الدوله الفرنسي ستقوم الذي حصل لنا
الامور اصاحب معاكسه تماما هنالك تطبيع
ودول مهمه وليست دول ثانويه همم
وجاء هذا التطبيع بمثابه نوع من الخروج عن
اساسيات المبادره العربيه للسلام ولا الان
هي كانها غير موجوده عمليا بعد ان تم هذا
الاختراق لذلك نعم انا اوافقك الراي بان
التطبيع الذي تم بين العديد من الدول
العربيه واسرائيل ادى الى همم القضيه
الفلسطينيه عن مكانها المركزي في
الدبلوماسيه العربيه خليني اقولها الرسميه
يعني الدبراس العربي الرسميه التي التزمت
بمبادره السلام وقدمت للعالم خطابا عربيا
دعم الفلسطينيين واجاب عن سؤال ان ليس لدى
العرب سياسه تجاه القضيه الفلسطينيه ولا
اتجاه السلام فاجابه بمبادره مستنيره جيده
مكتمله شروط ولكن هذه المبادره قومت من
قبل اسرائيل ولم تخدم من قبل العرب الى ان
اصبحت تقريبا في الارشيف وهذا شجع كثير من
الدول على ان تتجاوزها وان تقيم علاقات
همم خارج هذا الاطار مع اسرائيل نعم لقد
ادى التطبيع الذي تم مع بعض الدول العربيه
الى تراجع الاهتمام وتغيير الاولويات في
اسرائيل لان اصبحت اسرائيل تقول لا انا
بعمل حل مع العرب بعدين ما يت بشوف
الفلسطينيين شو ممكن اعمل معهم وهذا الان
اسالنا الدنيا بقول لك هيك بقول لك انه
انا خلص بديت بديت اكسر الحلقات العربيه
واحده بعد الاخرى وبالتالي بعد ما نخلص من
تطبيع عربي شامل وواسع النطاق بنبدا نحكي
في الموضوع الفلسطيني بيكون الفلسطيني
ساعتها في اضعف حالته لذلك نعم اوافقك على
ان الذي حدث اضعف الموقف الفلسطيني اضعف
القضيه الفلسطينيه اضعف النضال الوطني
الفلسطيني قيام دوله فلسطينيه مستقله هذا
ما لاحظناه جديا خلال سنوات التطبيعه طيب
طبعا تعليقا على ما يقوله بالعمر هل
اسرائيل لعبت ورقهت فرق تسد يعني استغلت
كل هذه الظروف التهديد الايراني مثل ما
تحدث ضيفي من القاهره على اساس انه ايران
اصبحت الخطر الاكبر ما جرى في داخل الدول
العربيه مثلما نعرف الربيع العربي بعد ذلك
همم هذا التطبيع استغلت هذه الفرصه لكي
تفرض كلمتها
هي طبعا استغلت هذه ولكن انا تصلي لي مش
بيعنا كان همم
تطبيقيه سلام بين الدول الغربيه اسرائيل
وهي التي
همم الفلسطينيات يعني كل الدول العربيه كل
الاعلام العربيه وصل الى النتيجه
[موسيقى]
يعني لا يوجد اي عمل لتحكم السلام ما هي
النتيجه علينا ان نستاني ان نلتزم
20 50 100 سنه لا نحن نويضوها
نقدمتنا يعني لا نريد كان الاول الرئيس
انور السادات قال انا ملتزم بالكبير
الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
مهمه جدا هذا ما كان له الملك همم
العين الاردني
[موسيقى]
ربما يعني اسرائيل
هي مسؤوله على بعضها اليما هي القوه
المحتله والحكومه الخليه لا تغيدوا الحال
يا تغدوا انضمام دمج هذه
نحن نعرف ذلك
سياسه الاستيطان لم تتوقف عمليات قتل
الفلسطينيين تقريبا يوميا العنف ازداد
يعني كيف في مثل هذه الظروف ان توفر ارضيه
خصبه لمحاوله ايجاد حل
لا طبعا يعني انا قلت من البدايه هذه
الحكومه لا الحكومه الخليعه والجايه في
اسرائيل
الاغراض الفلسطينيه همم
[موسيقى]
مليون همم هذه الحكومه لا تريد السلام مع
الفلسطيني بمعنى يعني كيام دوله فلسطينيه
همم والدول العربيه لا توجد عن تمتاز الى
العبد
بالعوده الى الوضع الفلسطيني الفلسطيني
يعني قياده فلسطينيه لم تتجدد امتعاث ايضا
من عدم تنظيم انتخابات الحديث في الجزائر
عن توصل الى الاتفاق لان طبعا مضمون
الاتفاق معروف ولكن كيف سيتبلول على الارض
كلها ايضا عوامل تساهم في اضعاف الموقف
الفلسطيني لا
يعني ايه
بس احب ارجع اذا سمحت لي يا استاذ توفيق
قبل ما ارد على سؤال حضرتك لي تعليق على
ما قالوا ضيفكم من اسرائيل واشارته الى
الرئيس الراحل انور السادات
معادله السلام المصريه الاسرائيليه اي اي
حد
يرجع الى ديباجه هذه المعاهده هيجد انه
اللي وقعه على هذه المعاهده مصر واسرائيل
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ربطته بين السلام بين مصر واسرائيل وبين
تسويه القضيه الفلسطينيه ده اول شيء
الامر الثاني ان احنا كنا فعلا بعد
التوقيع على المعاهده في 26 مارس 79
دخلنا اجرينا مفاوضات ما اطلق عليه في ذلك
الوقت مفاوضات
همم
تعريف مصر للحكم الذاتي ان هو بعد خمس
سنوات تنتقل السياده في الضفه الغربيه او
قطاع غزه الى الفلسطينيين اللي كود في ذلك
الوقت حزب النقود بقياده مناحن بيجن قال
ان هو لا هو مفهومه عن الحكم الذاتي ان هي
حكم ذاتي اداري بمعنى ان السياده ولا ننسى
ان اسرائيل هي قوه احتلال في الضفه
الغربيه هو كانت في قطاع غزه حتى 2005 ان
السياده تبقى لاسرائيل لكن نعطي نمنح
اسرائيل الحكم الذاتي الاداري وهو ما
رفضته من مصر في ظل قياده الرئيس السادات
وامر الرئيس السادات بانسحاب الوفد المصري
من هذا فدي اول حاجه بالنسبه بقى اعود
لسؤال حضرتك
الاوضاع داخل فلسطين همم مما لا شك فيه
مما لا شك فيه ان منذ القياده الفلسطينيه
الحاليه مع كل التقدير لكل الرموز
والقيادات الفلسطينيه وعندما اتحدث عن
القياده الفلسطينيه ليس فقط القياده قياده
السلطه الفلسطينيه وانما
سلطه الامر الواقع في قطاع غزه ان هذا
الجيل تم انتخابه حضرتك
بالنسبه للقطاع غزه
الحاليين القاده الحاليين تم انتخابهم في
2006 النهارده احنا في 2000 22 من 2006
لغايه 2000 22 في اجيال في شباب فلسطين في
مراه فلسطينيه في افكار جديده طلعت حضرتك
طب الورق داخل القطاع اذا نظرنا حضرتك في
الضفه الغربيه مع كل التقدير طبعا لرئيس
السلطه الفلسطينيه السيد محمود عباس هناك
ايضا هو حضرتك بالرغم انه كان اعلى ان في
انتخابات في 2021 همم سواء انتخابات
تشريعيه او انتخابات المجلس الوطني
الفلسطيني وانتخابات رئاسيه وده الامل في
ذلك الوقت جدد الامل في ذلك الوقت ان في
قيادات فلسطينيه في شباب فلسطين ح- هيواصل
رفع المشعل ورفع الرايه الفلسطينيه
والجهاد الفلسطيني لكن لسبب او لاخر همم
تم تاجيل هذه الانتخابات لاجل غير مسمى
بحيث ان النهارده همم يعني طبعا ده ده عذر
غير مقبول لكن انا عايز اقول ان اسرائيل
وانا ثانيه وخصوصا يعني عندما يتحدثون معه
عن المفاوضات يقول انا لا اجد امامي شريك
سلام فلسطين وهو طبعا ده يخالف الواقع
تماما ال- ال- ال- يجب يجب
انه القيادات الفلسطينيه يجب تجديد هذه
القيادات حتى حتى انا طبعا كلنا في اجماع
او شبه اجماع ان القضيه الفلسطينيه تراجعت
على سلم الاولويات للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وللاتحاد الاوروبي
والرباعيه الدوليه لكن انا اعتقد ان ممكن
حضرتك الجانب الفلسطيني بتاييد ومسند قويه
وواضحه من من الدول العربيه ان انه اجراء
هذه الانتخابات انا اعتقد حضرتك دي هيغير
من المعادله هيجعل هيجعل لن اتحدث عن
الداخل الاسرائيلي لان اسرائيل حضرتك همم
حتى المشهد في اسرائيل لما يتغير منذ زمان
اهو
نتنياهو هو حضرتك يعني من اول ما اجيب
الرقم اللي هو في يونيو 2009
وتحت
حتى ضغوط كبيره من اداره اوباما كان
ساعتها لسه اوباما حضرتك لم يمضي عليه في
البيت الابيض اكثر من خمس اشهر اعلن اعلن
في يونيو 2009 ان هو يقبل باقامه دوله
فلسطينيه لكن اما حتى اربع شروط لهذه
الدوله الفلسطينيه في ذلك الوقت قلنا ان
هو لا يتحدث عن دوله فلسطينيه مستقله
وانما يتحدث عن بل فستان فلسطيني فانا
تنياهو حضرتك احنا ثنياه وهو كقياده
اسرائيليه كياده اسرائيليه طبعا نتانيا من
اللكود لكن بالاضافه الى ان الكود بيمثل
اليمين واليمين المتطرف همم بدءا من مناح
في انتخابات ما له 77 نتنياه كقياده
اسرائيليه مسؤول امام التاريخ على هو الذي
اجهض
اي اي محاوله واي جهد صادق لاقامه الدوله
الفلسطينيه المستقله لكن بالرغم من ذلك
بالرغم من ذلك انا اعتقد شخصيا ان اراده
الشعب الفلسطيني
وصمود الشعب الفلسطيني هي في النهايه هي
اللي هتفرض على جميع الاطراف المعنيه
بالقضيه الفلسطينيه
بالعمل جديه لتنفيذ لتنفيذ حل الدولتين
لانه لامن لاسرائيل من امن اسرائيل
تفضل تسمعني
طيب هل تسمعوني ام لا
لم تعد تسمعني
في تل ابيب الان الاشكال هو الابتعاد عن
اي طريق يمكن ان يؤدي الى حل ولكن الا
توجد مجازه من قبل اسرائيل في حال البقاء
في هذه الحلقه المفرغه لان العنف لن يتوقف
وانت ترى ان العمليات تعددت في الداخل
الاسرائيلي في الفتره الاخيره
ماذا
يقولون ماذا يقولون
بعض
الاصغر
اليمين يكونوا بيانو بالنسبه لاسرائيل نحن
لا نتكلم على
ما هي ولكن على تغيير
[موسيقى]
في
نهايه الحلم
همم
وتحويل الفيسبوك الى مواطنين اسرائيلين
كما هو القلب في شرق القدس كما هو الخال
داخل اسرائيل طبعا لهذا همم هذا يعدي الى
همم
تسقيه والى بعد من المواجهات والى عمليات
الاغذيه ولكن
لمبه بهذه بهذا النوع من الامليان حتى
يعني ايام اسلوبه لا مكان في منطقه رئيس
الوزغه وهو يريد همم
الفصول على التقادم في عمليه كانت هناك
عمليات غبيه من قبل همم
يعني همم
اليمين الاسرائيلي وهو اليوم في الحكومه
يفهم السير الثوم
للبكاء همم وان كان لو ده على ما هي وهو
همم
امريكي من الخارج
امريكي ملموس هو الشيء الوحيد الذي يعدي
الى تغيير
موقف بالنسبه للكبير
طيب حسين الهريدي بانتظار ربط الخط مع
نبيل عمرو اعتقد انه لا يسمعني بعد في
مشكل تقني معه من من رام الله خلينا نتحدث
مع المثقف انت كمثقف وانت بالتاكيد تابعت
مدى حماس
المثقفين العرب والشعوب العربيه احيانا
القضيه الفلسطينيه
سابقا الان الوضع اختلف كليا هل تعتقد بان
الاوضاع العالميه الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
الاوضاع الشخصيه عدم وجود توعيه بالقضيه
حتى في المناهج المدرسيه هو الذي ساعد على
ذلك
[موسيقى]
يعني في مجموعه من العوامل حضرتك ممكن
تفسر ليه بعد ليس ليس كل الشعوب العربيه
وليس كل قطاعات في الشعوب العربيه هي التي
تخلت عن القضيه الفلسطينيه انا تقديري
المتواضع ان السواد الاعظم من المواطنين
العرب من المحيط الى الخليج ما زالوا
يقفون وكيف الرجل الواحد وراء حقوق الشعب
الفلسطيني
وهناك اسئله كثيره لماذا لا تتجدد القضيه
الفلسطينيه ما هي العراقيل امام ذلك لماذا
يعني اسئله اطرحه حتى الفلسطينيون
يعني لازم نتحدث ولو قليلا عن الوضع
الداخلي الفلسطيني
وصلته بتطور القضيه الفلسطينيه او بتذهب
سلبا وايجابا نعم
لقد حدث خطا كبير
اولا من خلال الانقسام الذي مازال مستمرا
ولمده تزيد عن 15 سنه تقريبا وهذا لاول
مره في التاريخ وهذا اضعف القضيه حتى سمي
بالنكبه الثانيه وعلينا ان نعترف بذلك
الشيء الثاني
اقتربنا من ان يجري انتخابات تشريعيه
تستطيع ان تتقدم خطوه جديه باتجاه النهائي
للانقسام من خلال مشاركه الجميع في هذه
الانتخابات وكان خطا فاتحا تاجيلها بمعنى
الغاءها لانه ليس تاجيلا وانما الغاء ولكن
بلغه التاجير الوضع الداخلي الفلسطيني
بحاجه الى ترميم بحاجه الى عمل كثير من
الان يتلاءم مع المرحله القادمه بما تحمله
من اخطار امامنا الان الوضع العربي الذي
اصبح منقسم باتجاه التطبيع من مع ومن ضد
وهذا تحدي الوضع الاسرائيلي اليمين
الاسرائيلي سياتي باشرس المتزمطين ليقفوا
في مواجهه الشعب الفلسطيني
قاده في اسرائيل ويعلنون ان وظيفتهم تصفيه
الموضوع الفلسطيني من جذوره وهذا ايضا
تحدي مثل امامنا الحرب الاوكرانيه الان
العالم كله منشغل بها ونحن كف فلسطينيين
علينا ان نضعف جهودنا لكي نظل داخل
المعادله كل هذه الامور تحدثتم ان نبدا
بحاله بترميم الوضع الفلسطيني المتداعي
انقسامات عديده يجب ان تتوقف يجب ان يعود
الفلسطيني الى عمل المؤسسات يجب ان يذهب
الى الانتخابات لتجديد قياداتته كل هذه
المسائل يجب ان تعمل وعلى الفور والا
الامور تتجاوزنا بمراحل كثيره اقر بان
الوضع الفلسطيني الداخلي كان احد الاسباب
التي تعيق همم التقدم باتجاه القضيه
الفلسطينيه على الصعيد العربي والمحلي
والدولي ولكن في نفس الوقت انا اقول
بالمقابل في في اسرائيل نوع من الانكار
المطلق للفلسطينيين والاستثمار في القتال
معهم اسرائيل خاسره ايضا لانه الفلسطينيين
على ارضهم موجودين ولا حل لدى اسرائيل
لهؤلاء بيطلع كل يوم تشكيل فلسطيني يخرج
من الطاقه المفاوضات والحل السياسي الى
العمل المسلح وهذه المساله تعاني منها
اسرائيل كثيرا لانها هي التي تستثمر في
تصدير العنف للفلسطينيين واستكبر رد الفعل
العنيف من الفلسطينيين وبالتالي لم يعد
هنالك فرصه الان ل- لعمليه سلام انا اقول
على الفلسطيني ان يرمي وضعه داخلي لمزيد
صمود ليس من اج يحرز نتائج في المفاوضات
لا المفاوضات ابتعدت كثيرا باليمين
الاسرائيلي والموقف الامريكي ولكن من اجل
ان يحافظ على ما تبقى اين يظل الشعب
الفلسطيني على ارضه قوي وسياتي التطور
دولي ربما يستطيع من ان يدخل الفلسطيني
الى المفاوضات الى الحلول اوافق على ان
الوضع الداخلي الفلسطيني يجب ان يتجدد
ويجب ان يتغير ويجب ان يتقدم والا فسيكون
الوضع في غير مصلحه الفلسطينيين على المدى
القريب المتوسط والبعيد طيب من هو رجل
المرحله بعد محمود عباس الان في فلسطين
لا يوجد لدينا رجل مرحله وهذه مفرد لا
تتناسب مع المستوى الحضاري للشعب
الفلسطيني
المرحله القادمه من يخلف محمود عباس هو
الذي يخرج من صندوق الاقتراع بانتخابات
حره ونزيهه ويشرف عليها العالم كله
لنتباهى بها نحن شعب ديمقراطي لا نستطيع
ان نقول هذا ياتي وذاك لا ياتي دون
الانتخابات لا امل بايجاد نظام سياسي
فلسطيني جدي يستطيع ان يحافظ على الحقوق
الوطنيه وعلى وضع الشعب الفلسطيني لا نريد
ان ندخل في قصه الاسماء نحن الاسراف نحن
نرى ان الشعب الفلسطيني حتى ياسر عرفات
الذي كان رمزه وقائدا مركزيا وقائدا
تاريخيا دخل الى الانتخابات وفاز بنسبه
همم معقول في الانتخابات مش التسعات اللي
بتعرفوها عن الدول العربيه هو محمود عباس
ايضا اصبح رئيسا بالانتخابات اذا لماذا
انا لا افكر برئيس يخرج من صندوق الاقتراع
بصيغه ملفقه لكي ياتي رئيس الشعب
الفلسطيني صندوق الاقتراع هو الذي ينتج
الرئيس الفلسطيني الشرعي والمقنع
للفلسطينيين وللعالم طيب هي الزسر الان
تساؤلات حتى على الداخل الاسرائيلي يعني
اين هو اليسار الاسرائيلي الذي كان يدافع
عن القضيه الفلسطينيه كانت صحف تكتب كانت
صحف تنتقد بكثره وكاني بالراي العام
الاسرائيلي مال مع حكومته الى اقصى اليمين
يعني هذا هو هذه هي الصيغه اعتقد مثلا نحن
نتكلم اليوم على هذه الانتخابات الاخيره
بيانا انتشار كبير لليمين ولكن انتخابات
2006 بعد الانسحاب الاسرائيلي المطلق من
الكتاب كان انتصار مطلق لليسار
حتى يعني
من كل ال ال الكتابه نحن كتاب غزه
الى دوله فلسطينيه ولا لكن دوله خماس يعني
كان هناك كلاب مثلا
على الفلسطينيات
فلسطين ان يحول منطقه همم الكتاب الى
منطقه سلام مش منطقه حمستانه التي تهدد
الامن همم العمد الاسرائيلي كما هي تهدد
نحن نعرف ذلك همم
شمال همم
يعني هذه هي قطوه جميله خطوه طول العلم
ممكن تجنيده اللي عاجل القضيه همم في
الاستماع يعني اذا تحولت همم رسم من همم
حكم حماس الى حكم يعني كل العالم يضغط على
اسرائيل يعني
الحدود مع مثل المفتوح يعني
في اشياء ممكن نعمل لها ولكن للاسف الشديد
حتى الي يستغل الاسرائيلي
هو القلب بالنسبه للدول العربيه ليس ممتم
بالكرديه الفلسطينيه لانه لا يعتقد خليها
بان هناك
في هذه العمليه
تتحدث عن شعب فلسطيني عن صمود شعب فلسطيني
ولكن انت تدرك جيدا اكثر مني باعتبارنك
مطلع على هذه القضيه منذ فتره طويله
وتابعت هذا الملف الدعم المالي العربي
للقضيه الفلسطينيه ولل فلسطينيه تراجع
بشكل كبير خلال السنوات الاخيره ودون هذا
الدعم
هل يمكن للشعب الفلسطيني ان يصمد بنفس
الطريقه التي صمد بها حتى الان
الشعب الفلسطيني اييي مؤمن بقضيته الشعب
الفلسطيني يرفض الاستمرار في الحياه تحت
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وما تق- الممارسات
اللا انسانيه التي تقوم بها القوات
الاسرائيليه الشعب الفلسطيني بيرفض وحيرفض
ان هو يستمر يحيى تحت الحصار الاسرائيلي
جائر لقطاع غزه الذي اا لا لم نراه خلال
الثلاث القرون ال- ال- ال- الماضيه همم
فانا حضرتك مؤمن ليس فقط مع ذلك القضيه
همم القضيه الفلسطينيه وانما بصمود الشعب
الفلسطيني طبعا همم في المرحله القادمه
وحتى
وحتى 2024 نتمنى على كافه الحكومات
العربيه ان هي تدعم الشعب الفلسطيني ليس
فقط اليا وانما تدعموا سياسيا وتدعممه
معنويا وتدعمه همم دوليا وان الانطباع
الذي يردده او
التصريحات اللي بيرددها نتنياهو التي
اخرها بعد انتخابه وقال ان انا هاستمر في
سياستي واستراتيجيتي لاقامه علاقات
دبلوماسيه مع الدول العربيه ثم بعد ذلك
نرى همم
ما يمكن ان نقدمه للقضيه الفلسطينيه يجب
ان هذا الطرح يجب ان ترفضه الدول العربيه
النقطه الاخرى حضرتك لماذا انا ذكرت 2000
24 لانه من يناير القادم
ايه ايه لحتى 2024 اللي هو موعد اجراء
الانتخابات الرئاسيه في الولايات المتحده
في نوفمبر 2023 في يناير القادم يعني كمان
اقل من شهرين الاغلبيه في مجلس النواب
هتذهب الى الحزب الجمهوري هنا تنياهو وانا
تنياهو وانا استطيع ان اؤكد ذلك حضرتك يا
استاذ توفيق ان نتنياهو هيعيد نفس اللعبه
التي قام بها خلال اداره اوباما واختار اا
عندما كانت الاغلبيه جمهوريه ان هو يتعاون
مع هذه الجمهوريه وعلاقته بالحزب الجمهوري
الامريكي علاقه وطيده وطبعا رايناها في
قيمتها وذروتها خلال همم رئاسه ترامب همم
ان هو هيعيد مره اخرى الاستراتيجيه اللي
هو التلويح دائما بالتهديد الايراني وانه
وما يسميه بين مزدوج الدين الارهابي
الفلسطيني طبعا لا يوجد ما يسمى بالارهاب
الفلسطيني هو دوت حضرتك يعني اللي عمل معه
وهو بيؤجل هذا الطرح يجب ان ترفضه الدول
العربيه ولا يمكن ولا يمكن تخيل او تصور
ان في دول عربيه هتقوم بالتطبيع مع
الحكومه الاسرائيليه القادمه حكومه
نتنياهو
بالصهيونيه الدينيه ممثله في همم همم
حضرتك همم ممثله في اعتى ممثلي اليمين
المطرف الاسرائيلي لا يمكن لا يمكن تخيل
ان في حكومه عربيه ساعه توافق على التطبيع
او ان هي تقييم اتصالات مع هذه الحكومه
اليمين المتطرفه فانا شايف حضرتك ان من
الان لغايه عام 2024 هو عام تحدي ليس فقط
امام القيادات الفلسطينيه سواء في السلطه
الفلسطينيه او في حماس او في الجهاد
الاسلامي
وانما امام الحكومات والدول العربيه ان
خلال هذه فتره لا ينبغي ولا يجب ان يفلت
نتنياهو من مسؤولياته ومسؤوليات اسرائيل
قوه احتلال الاتجاه الشعب الفلسطيني في
ختام هذا البرنامج نبيل عمره رايك فيما
يتعلق بتراجع الدعم المالي العربي
للفلسطينيين
لا هو يعني الدعم المالي العربي مرتبط
ايضا بتراجع الدعم السياسي
وبتراجع الهجوم السياسي العربي كما كان في
بعض المراحل السابقه وبعدين الى الان همم
بدنا نذكر بشيء بكل اسف يعني انا
التطبيع الذي تم معنى الدنيا في الاساس
وبالتالي يجب ان يكون ذلك حذر شديد مما هو
قادم من خلال ربما تتطور
اتمنى ان ما يقولوا سعاده السفير يلتزم به
عربيا بعد ان ياتي اليوم كان اليمين الذي
يحكم عندما بدات التطبيعه اود ان اقول شيء
خلاصه الامر ان الشعب الفلسطيني
مختلف كليا عن الحسابات التي تتعرض لها
القوى السياسيه مثلا الشعب الفلسطيني شعب
مبادرات
متمسك بالاساسيات مازال وفعال في هذا
المجال هو متمسك بقائه على ارضه لا هروب
لا هجره له متمسك بعدم الادعان ولا قبول
السياسه الاسرائيليه مهما كانت مغرياتها
متمسك ايضا باصدار مبادرات كفاحيه على
مستويات متعدده وعلاء اسرائيل ان تفهم هذا
جيدا اذا لم يستريح الشعب الفلسطيني وتصل
اليه حقوقه فان اسرائيل لم تستريح كل يوم
تعود الامور الى السفر الى ما دون الصفر
عمليات في القدس عمليات في شمال فلسطين
عمليات في النقب هذا كله نتيجه عدم وجود
افق سياسي والنتيجه عدم وجود نافذه سياسيه
يستطيع الشعب الفلسطيني ان يرى منها املا
على اسرائيل ان تدرك خطوره ما تفعل عليها
اولا وبعد ذلك على الاخر الاخرين الشكر في
الختاملي حسين هريدي وهو مساعد وزير
الخارجيه المصري الاسبق الشكر من رام الله
لنبيل عمرو وزير فلسطيني السابق والشكر
لله الجسر وبروفيسور في قسم دراسات الشرق
الاوسط في جامعه تل ابيب الشكر لفريق
البرنامج خمس ايام مريحه للجميع
[موسيقى]